ya hemos aprendido que la respiración
celular verdad respiración celular está
dividida esencialmente en tres fases
verdad y la primera de ellas es la
glucólisis la primera de estas fases es
la glucólisis glucólisis que digamos
significa esencialmente que vamos a
romper la glucosa verdad significa
rompimiento de la molécula de glucosa
muy bien de la glucosa y luego bueno
después de este proceso puede ocurrir
digamos dos posibilidades una cuenta con
oxígeno y la otra no cuenta con oxígeno
va sin oxígeno verdad si no tenemos
oxígeno entonces digamos entramos a una
fase conocida como fermentación
está
muy bien es la fase de la fermentación y
hablaremos de esto en un vídeo futuro es
verdad pero en este caso en la
fermentación por ejemplo en humanos
producimos ácido láctico y en otro tipo
de organismos podemos producir alcohol o
etanol digamos ok pero si tenemos
oxígeno y en la mayoría de los casos
vamos a suponer que digamos que contamos
con suficiente oxígeno verdad si hay
oxígeno entonces podemos seguirnos hacia
el ciclo de krebs muy bien después de la
glucólisis en presencia de oxígeno
podemos ir al ciclo de krebs ciclo de
krebs y también se le conoce como el
ciclo de el ácido cítrico porque pues
justamente trata con ácido cítrico
verdad el mismo ácido cítrico que hay en
el jugo de naranja o en el jugo de los
limones ok después del ciclo de krebs
podemos continuar hacia lo que es la
cadena de transporte de electrones que
simplemente voy a poner así 7 cadena de
transporte de electrones
y aprendimos en el primer vídeo de la
respiración celular que es justo en la
cadena de transporte de electrones donde
la mayoría de los atp se van a producir
ok por supuesto vamos a necesitar la
materia prima que proviene de estas
fases anteriores ahora bien lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es
concentrarme en la glucólisis y en
realidad esto no es una tarea fácil
porque a veces puede uno enredarse en
todo este proceso de hecho les voy a
enseñar dentro de poco todos los enredos
que hay en este mecanismo verdad que
puede ser bastante aparatoso pero lo que
quiero es tratar de simplificar lo más
que se pueda para que sea un poco más
claro y así digamos cuando cuando
miremos a los detalles completos de la
glucólisis entonces eso tenga un poco
más de sentido así que la glucólisis es
el inicio de la respiración celular
verdad y comienza con una molécula de
glucosa muy bien vamos a poner aquí la
glucosa que de hecho también conocemos
su fórmula química es c 6 h 12
6 incluso podríamos dibujar todas las
estructuras aunque eso me llevaría un
poco de tiempo así que solo voy a
centrarme en los átomos de carbono y voy
a dibujarlo digamos como 6 carbonos en
fila muy bien entonces tenemos aquí 1 2
3 4 5 6 carbonos en fila verdad y ahora
bien hay dos tipos digamos hay dos fases
importantes en la glucólisis que siempre
es bueno conocer y digamos a la primera
yo les llamo la fase de inversión y
porque es la fase de inversión es
justamente donde vamos a invertir dos
moléculas de atp muy bien aquí vamos a
usar dos moléculas de atp ahí está
nuestra inversión verdad entonces tú ya
conoces que todo el propósito de la
respiración celular es generar atp es
verdad pero en este primer momento
necesitamos utilizar 2 atp es verdad así
que usamos 2 atp y luego lo que va a
ocurrir esencialmente es que vamos a
romper la molécula de la glucosa en
dos moléculas y esas dos moléculas
tienen tres átomos de carbono cada una
muy bien tenemos estas dos moléculas que
verdad y luego vamos a tener grupos
fosfatos unidos a estas moléculas
entonces vamos a poner aquí un grupo
fosfato que solo solo lo voy a digamos a
digamos a escribir de esta forma verdad
aunque puede ser un poco distinto y
estos grupos fosfato en realidad vienen
de estos 2 atp es verdad ahí es en donde
vamos a utilizar nuestra inversión
entonces a este grupo fosfato que se
unió a nuestra molécula que tiene tres
átomos de carbono bueno esta molécula
tiene muchos nombres pero a veces se le
llama pegar muy bien
de gard y también tiene otro nombre con
el que se le conoce que es el fósforo
glee será aldehído fósforo visceral de
ido
y todo un reto para nuestro nuestro
deletrea digamos para nuestra ortografía
de las moléculas digamos verdad pero
bueno ahí tenemos los fósforos lizer
aldehídos y digamos la parte esencial
que hay que conocer en esta primera fase
es que utilizamos 2 atp es verdad por
eso le llamamos fase de inversión vamos
a escribirlo así a esta parte vamos a
conocerlo como la fase de inversión fase
de inversión y lo voy a poner entre
comillas porque en realidad es sólo una
metáfora de lo que ocurre con los
sistemas financieros verdades es la fase
de inversión después cada una de estas
moléculas de pedal pueden ir a lo que es
digamos como la fase de recompensa
verdad o la fase de retribución así que
en esta en esta segunda fase para cada
una de estas moléculas pegar vamos a
producir digamos otra molécula que
también tiene tres átomos de carbono
pero esta se le conoce de otra forma y
es virus
muy bien esto sería piruvato tenemos
piruvato o también se lo conoce como
bueno no es que sea exactamente lo mismo
pero están muy relacionados con el ácido
piru vic o ácido úrico
son moléculas de tres átomos de carbono
que por supuesto están digamos
reconfigurados verdad entonces estos dos
el piruvato y el ácido úrico están
relacionados y esto es esencialmente el
producto final de la glucólisis verdad
si empezamos con una glucosa verdad
entramos a la fase de inversión usamos 2
atp es formamos fósforo glee será el de
aído que es digamos con este producto
que se rompió digamos de la glucosa y al
agregar fosfato en los extremos de las
mismas verdad también obtenemos los
fósforos herald e idos y luego cada uno
de forma independiente va a producir
piruvato verdad y esto ocurre por cada
una de las moléculas de glucosa con las
que empezamos verdad que se producen 2
fósforo glitter aldehídos y cada una de
estas produce un piro bato entonces tú
te estarás preguntando oye
aquí dice es que hubo una fase de
ganancia o de recompensa bueno cuál es
esa ganancia o cuál es esa recompensa
verdad entonces la fase digamos de
recompensa sería ésta
la fase de recompensa y vamos a ponerlo
entre comillas porque es una digamos una
metáfora con los sistemas de
empresariales verdad entonces esta es
nuestra fase de recompensa y la
recompensa es la siguiente cuando
digamos vamos del fósforo glitter
aldehído al piruvato en realidad vamos a
poder producir 2 atp es 2 atp es muy
bien y también vamos a poder producir
nh n de h muy bien esto por supuesto
también pasa con la otra aquí se
producen 2 atp también vamos a producir
nh n de h muy bien y por supuesto verdad
nos están solo produciendo esas
moléculas de la nada verdad lo que están
haciendo es digamos utilizar la materia
prima que sería un n además verdad
vamos a ponerlo aquí en realidad por ahí
encuentran un n además que después se
reduce para producir este n de verdad
que es simplemente agregar un hidrógeno
y nosotros aprendimos hace un par de
vídeos que podríamos ver a la reducción
como una ganancia de hidrógeno es verdad
así que el n además se reduce en n a de
h verdad y luego estos n a dh se
utilizan en la cadena de transporte de
electrones para producir más atp es muy
bien entonces en resumen si nosotros
empezamos con una glucosa verdad vamos a
escribir digamos una especie de reacción
por acá abajo si nosotros empezamos con
glucosa vamos a poner aquí en que
empezamos con glucosa digamos este
proceso necesita algunos n además verdad
y vamos a poner 2 porque utilizamos 1 en
cada lado
vamos a necesitar también 2 atp s
2 atp s y también vamos a necesitar 4 a
de pez muy bien vamos a necesitar 4 a bp
y en en esencia aquí lo único que estoy
escribiendo son los ingredientes que
necesitamos para empezar con digamos
esta reacción muy bien además vamos a
necesitar también cuatro grupos fosfato
entonces vamos a agregar vamos a agregar
4 4 boots vamos a ponerlo así con otro
color más cuatro grupos fosfato que son
justamente los que he puesto aquí y una
vez que se lleva a cabo la glucólisis es
decir esta reacción que es lo que vamos
a obtener pues vamos a obtener dos
moléculas de piruvato dos moléculas de
piruvato vamos a obtener dos moléculas
de nh
dh en realidad es porque se redujo el n
además verdad en nh is y lo vemos en el
sentido biológico verdad estamos
pensando que gana hidrógeno en realidad
el hidrógeno es poco electro negativo
por lo que en realidad están acaparando
sus electrones así que tenemos 2n a de h
luego vamos a tener estos dos a de pez
de hecho al usarse en la fase de
inversión estos 2 atp se convierten en 2
a bp y esencialmente estos 4 a de pez se
van a convertir en 4 atp muy bien
tenemos 4 atp es creo que aquí en
realidad no necesitamos 4 si no vamos a
poner que son dos grupos fosfato netos
lo que ocurre aquí es que en este mismo
proceso surgen dos grupos fosfato pero
necesitamos cuatro de ellos así que en
realidad sólo necesitaríamos dos más
verdad son dos netos en digamos los que
se requieren en este proceso pero
digamos el panorama es que empezamos con
una glucosa verdad luego vamos a obtener
dos piru gatos
2 piruvato 2 vamos a ponerlo así 2
piruvato es verdad si usamos 2 atp
después vamos a obtener 4 atp así que
digamos vamos a obtener 2 atp netos muy
bien y digamos vamos a escribir en
grande lo que se obtiene de la
glucólisis muy bien vamos a escribir en
grande esto de los que se obtiene
esencialmente vamos a tener digamos neto
vamos a tener 2 atp 2 a tp vamos a tener
2 n de h y vamos a tener también 2
piruvato virus datos muy bien esto es
digamos lo que obtenemos al final de la
glucólisis digamos por este mecanismo
verdad veamos el mecanismo un poco más
complicado verdad porque esto en
realidad es más difícil de como lo he
planteado aquí verdad pero vamos a ver
digamos los mismos temas de los que ha
hablado vamos a empezar con una molécula
de glucosa verdad que es esa que está
hasta digamos como señalada con ver de
verdad aquí tenemos nuestra molécula de
glucosa
podemos ver que tiene 6 átomos de
carbono aquí van 2 4 5 6 digamos están
en forma de anillo y digamos si pudiera
escribirlo de esta forma justamente
sería la cadena que tenía anteriormente
verdad
digamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 verdad entonces
justamente aquí tenemos nuestra molécula
de glucosa y lo que vemos es que a
través de ciertos pasos vamos a utilizar
atp es aquí utilizamos uno aquí
utilizamos otro y aquí estamos viendo
que estamos usando 2 atp es verdad y
obtenemos una molécula muy interesante
que se llama glee será leído 3 fosfato
como te había mencionado en realidad
este es el fósforo glitter aldehído que
también se le conoce como pegar pero
bueno también tiene varios nombres aquí
está digamos se muestra que es un
blíster aldehído 3 fosfato o al menos
así se
hombre en esta imagen verdad sí pero es
la misma molécula verdad esta que
tenemos aquí son los fósforos literal de
y 2 o pegar de hecho aquí se pueden ver
nuestras nuestros tres átomos de carbono
que están unidos a través de un oxígeno
con el grupo fosfato es como lo que yo
tenía antes tenía mis tres tenía mis
tres átomos de carbono unidos con
nuestro grupo fosfato que simplemente lo
puse así que aquí podemos ver en
amarillo y algo muy importante que hay
que recordar es que hay dos de estos
glitter aldehído 3 fosfato verdad aquí
por ejemplo dice que tenemos una
reacción que puede ir hacia adelante y
hacia atrás en esta en esta reacción
digamos con este tipo de isómeros pero
lo importante es que tenemos dos de
estos compuestos verdad que ahora son
compuestos de tres átomos de carbono la
glucosa se ha dividido en ellos y ahora
estamos listos para entrar en la fase de
recompensas y que recordemos qué
dos de estos compuestos de aquí entonces
vamos a tener que considerar esto y para
cada uno de estos fog literal de idos
podemos fijarnos en el mecanismo y decir
ok mira aquí por ejemplo van a convertir
un en un atp en un atp de verdad aquí
vamos a marcarlo aquí estamos
convirtiendo un atp en un atp y más
adelante va a ocurrir exactamente lo
mismo
verdad por ejemplo aquí arriba aquí
arriba vamos a poder convertir otro atp
en un atp es decir por cada uno de estos
grises fósforo glitter aldehídos podemos
producir dos moléculas de atp pero como
teníamos dos fósforo glitter aldehídos
entonces en realidad tenemos una
producción de 4 atp es verdad ya estamos
en la fase de recompensa entonces en
esta fase de recompensa obtenemos 4 a
tps pero en la fase de inversión
utilizamos 2 atp es así que digamos el
total de atp es netos generados por la
glucólisis es
2 atp ahora bien también tenemos el n
además verdad que se va a convertir en
un n se va a reducir vemos que por cada
fósforo glitter aldehído vamos a tener
una reducción de n además en nh verdad y
esto sucede para cada uno de los
fósforos literal de y 2 por lo tanto
vamos a tener una producción de 2 n de h
es verdad y eso es más tarde van a ser
utilizados en la cadena de transporte de
electrones para producir 3 atp es verdad
y finalmente verdad vamos a obtener los
dos pilotos que hemos mencionado y aquí
tenemos el digamos la molécula del
piruvato y tal como lo hemos prometido
podemos observar todos los enlaces que
hay por ejemplo con los oxígenos y todo
eso pero en esencia lo que hay que notar
es que esta es una estructura de tres
átomos de carbono verdad aquí tenemos
los tres átomos de carbono así digamos
el resultado final es que la glucosa se
dividió por la mitad digámoslo así se
oxidó verdad algunos de los átomos de
hidrógeno se quita
y como podemos ver aquí sólo tenemos
cuatro átomos de hidrógeno cuando
originalmente teníamos dos de verdad
comenzamos con 12 átomos de hidrógeno en
la glucosa y ahora tiene sus átomos de
carbono digamos unidos de forma más
fuerte con el oxígeno verdad por lo que
esencialmente está teniendo que sus
electrones son acaparados por los
oxígenos por lo tanto el carbono se ha
oxidado en este proceso ok y en este
proceso hemos podido generar 2 atp es
netos vamos a escribirlo aquí hemos
podido generar 2 atp netos y también
hemos podido producir 2n a de h
muy bien 12 nh y que después pueden
utilizarse posteriormente para producir
atp es bueno de todas formas espero que
este vídeo te haya parecido útil